there's a um documentary on netflix i
don't know if you saw it but about
a dude who was doing the deep-sea diving
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah i know that guy but
yeah
i don't know him personally but i've got
one of my best friends
who i work with is very good friends
with him was that your job it's called
last breath yeah yes you were one of
those yep okay i'm gonna briefly
summarize what happened in this
documentary tell me if i'm [ __ ] up
okay
they are
diving
i already i already [ __ ] it up
this guy's had one sip of his drink
i [ __ ] it up where are they diving bro
okay so they're in the north sea
off of scotland basically it's [ __ ]
horrible it's freezing cold yeah
there's there's more rain in scotland
probably than anywhere else in the world
that sounds fun
we had a guy from new york there was a
former marine yeah and he's walking up
the pier with me and the rain is
smashing him in the face and i'm looking
i'm going
this is [ __ ] isn't it and he's like man
this [ __ ] place is hell on earth
welcome to scotland boys
so yeah they're diving off off the uh
off the course and uh they basically
like pressurized for a whole month so
they live in a tiny uh
bell that's what they call it basically
where they go out into uh another bell
they get lower down do their bit 12-hour
shift for the day come back up sleep and
uh
they they put this guy out there and the
the
the boat uh what keeps the boat in place
so that the divers can stay on the job
yeah failed yeah so because it's not
anchors uh so so the the boat is getting
pushed by the corridor by the storm yeah
and uh the diver's uh umbilical cord
which is what gives him his hot water is
uh breathing everything gets wrapped
around something snaps and he's just
left for dead so keep that in mind it's
not like diving has we we'd see people
do with this big [ __ ] tank no they're
hooked up because they're so far down
yeah so it's not like air diving where
you can go to like 50 me as you go
around you have a look at a nice little
bit of fish and a bit of [ __ ]
treasure or whatever like this is like
you are there to live there underwater
for about a month yeah uh
so yeah he was he was so far down it was
like just so [ __ ] yeah is it like a
mini submarine like this
they pressurize and then they just leave
you down there and you live in that
pressurized environment you're breathing
helium as well so your voice is squeaky
as [ __ ] for a whole month yeah that was
actually how [ __ ] scotland is they
would rather live under the water
but these guys are making
about a thousand pounds a day these guys
are making to do this and that's what
you were doing well i wasn't doing it
quite as deep as what they they i didn't
go as deep as them if you know what i
mean but yeah it basically the same job
as them yeah yeah okay so the guy's
umbilical cord gets snapped yep it tied
around something snaps
he climb he's completely lost you can't
see any of you can't see you know it's
black black yep right
um
he finds he just gets lucky walks back
to the oil
extraction site
uh basically yeah the job that he was on
yeah finds a way to climb up it again
you can't see anything you can't even
see your hand in front of you just
lays down on top of it
runs out of oxygen runs out of warmth
right it's freezing down there and
pressure too right uh well i guess he's
already he's all right because he's
pressurized but yeah he's basically not
breathing anything i don't know didn't
breathe for 30 minutes yeah uh 30
minutes he didn't breathe
i don't think yes
30
minutes i got 30 minutes worth of oxygen
right there you will not breathe if you
do two of those all right
like you're [ __ ] careful
the facts okay so you've been down there
yep
okay
for how long
sometimes i was doing a few hours but
you wouldn't do the month straight no so
mine was a lot more like um uh it was
like air diving instead of sat diving so
this dude basically it depends on what
you're what you're breathing but so like
i would be like
it was like [ __ ] miserable yeah
there was days where so i'm underwater
and i'm like using like pressurized
hoses where i'm blasting concrete off of
their piles under water that uh like
keep the um the pier up for example to
uh
like basically repair uh appear that's
old and [ __ ] yeah and
then you're getting out and you're
surrounded by like military guys
and i was like a young kid i just wanted
to go out meet women drink and uh and to
be fair a lot of the guys were like that
but like you're looking around and like
they're like 40 odd year old guys who
are doing like coke and viagra like yeah
it was wild yeah so it taught me a lot
about life did you did you get into
those habits i didn't get into
necessarily those habits but i was
definitely
i was running as fast as i could to keep
up with everything that they were
telling me to do you know i mean i i was
uh
i was just shocking everything i could
do you know what i mean yeah and um
and that was the first time i've had
money scottish glasses yeah yeah how's
that
um
scottish glasses are wild they're wild
they're [ __ ] mental wild like wolves
that have just been left out yeah
like like before you even had a first
date send you a picture of um
[ __ ] right uh no a dildo in her arse
and a dildo in her [ __ ]
so they're all like big [ __ ] like yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's where
my mom's from you think they think
you're they're doing you a favor when
they try to kill you in scotland like
yeah
this is horrible let's just get you out
of this mess yeah yeah no but my mom
left
my mom doesn't know what a [ __ ] dildo
is
i would never disrespect your mom mama
disrespect your heritage
maybe you can go out but i know that my
mom specifically has no [ __ ] clue
what a diligence have you been back with
scotland say again i went there yeah
yeah
braveheart yeah yeah i went i saw my
people i know what my my clan is about i
know what they stand for they're [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah no no we don't [ __ ]
them we stole them and what we do with
our stolen sheep is none of your [ __ ]
maybe you've got maybe you've got
confused as a scottish woman had a
little sex well that's the thing you you
know you tried
i've only been in a scottish [ __ ] one
time
and i know i don't remember much of it
but i was there for a while so i must
have like just show you yeah you're like
a deep-seat diver you were in there just
[ __ ]
but yeah so i think scottish women are
absolutely beautiful
and then maybe they're an acquired taste
for you guys do you know what i'm saying
better than anything
[ __ ] that's one thing i will they don't
take [ __ ] yeah you got to be careful
they will like because i did try your
viagra one of those old guys yeah yeah
and uh he was like about half an hour
beforehand just take this now i'm in my
early 20s i don't need viagra yeah what
the [ __ ] was he doing giving me viagra
yeah i literally put a shift in on her
to a point where the next morning
i put a shift in lads all right
and obviously we've got to get changed
in front of each other
and literally right my back
you ever seen silence of the lambs where
the fingernails are still in the bricks
yeah my back was like that the boys were
like what the [ __ ] happened i went he
gave us a [ __ ] viagra that's what
happened i couldn't come i was going for
like nine hours
we were having a cup of tears in between
just like so
dad is women scottish swimming for you
they love it
yeah but they like it they like dick
right oh yeah my mom would my mom have
sex a lot with my dad yeah yeah how many
kids did she end up with well just two
just two yeah yeah yeah yeah but they
would have like sex for not kids a lot
yeah yeah
yeah sex were not kids that's one sex or
not yes so she just loved it dude really
did you hear it you have a walk all the
time wow yeah yeah they're loud
honestly
yeah dude my dad was saying the same
[ __ ]
why why were you into why were you
deep-sea diving like why why was that
career
i found a video on youtube and i'd i'd
done uh engineering beforehand and they
were like yo if you're an engineer you
can make a [ __ ] ton of money by doing
this underwater because it's basically
danger money and i've seen that and i
was like well i'm not making good money
on [ __ ] land yeah it's all gone then
and yeah i just tried it out wow yeah
wild
engineering what kind of engineering i
was mechanical engineering [ __ ]
not really no engineering is [ __ ]
hard any engineering
that's for sure i was pretty dumb in the
class
yeah but